your experience of reality is entirely
subjective it's entirely arbitrary if
you were born unable to see you would
have a better sense of hearing if you
were born with your eyes and upside down
your entire view of the world would flip
on its head if you lived on a
mountainside like a mountain goat
you'd be perfect of balancing and you'd
never fall your brain adapt to its
environment and that's what dictates the
way you experience the world around you
this is thanks to something called brain
plasticity
brain plasticity also called
neuroplasticity describes your brain's
ability to change shape depending on
your actions experiences your memories
even your thoughts the most structure of
your brain changes shape if you learn
something new it creates new neural
pathways in your brain and every time
you a hearse that thing you've learned
it changes the structure by
strengthening that connection through my
other nation and through long term
potentiation in other words if you think
you're praying like a mind map every
time you have a new experience you
create a new branch and a new node and
then anytime you a hearse that
experience that branch increases in
strength and becomes stronger and easier
to access in the future if you do this
enough eventually it become it can
become so insect in your brain but it
becomes almost an instinctual
Association this is why people who
completely lose their memory in
accidents can sometimes play the piano
perfectly fluidly even though they
haven't played it for years meeting at
the car remember their own names
sometimes what fires together wires
together what does this mean it means
that if two neurons fire at the same
time this creates a slight association
so every time there's two nuanced
products having the same time the
Association strengthens and thereby rate
plasticity occurs a lot of other things
are also involved in this process BDNF
is brain derived neurotrophic factor and
this is a substance produced in the
brain that supports the growth of new
neurons new dendrites axons and sigh
maxes you also have nerve growth factor
and this also increases the growth of
new neural connections and increases the
length and the number of your brain
cells brain cells can be born by a
process called neurogenesis we used to
think that after certain age you stopped
creating new brain cells but this
actually turned out to be incorrect you
can create new brain cells at any age so
basically what you need to know is that
brain plasticity recursive rehearsal
every time you have something you cause
you are surprised at the same time if
you focus on it this increases your
awareness of it this increases your
production of dopamine
norepinephrine and this makes you it's
celebrated whatever you're doing is
important as a result we produce more
BDNF more nerve growth factor and as a
result of that the memory becomes
solidified or the action becomes
solidified your brain changes shape as
mentioned though this can be far more
found than just learning a new skill or
just picking up a new memory your entire
structure to break to change shape
that's why as I said if you're born
without the sight then you can enhance
your hearing if you're young enough you
can have a hemispherectomy between the
entire half of your brain is removed and
so plastic is the brain that the other
half is able to adapt and change shape
and take on all of the roles of the
other half was missing and thereby you
better be normal despite missing half
the brain so you bring them to
incredible things and I think there's
incredible potential here for changing
our own brains are making ourselves
smarter as the crow instance has
recently been discovered that
synesthesia can be learned since easier
is the ability to see colors when you
hear sounds or to feel certain ways when
you see letters a lot of people say it's
like a secret superpower and helps them
with memory and this can be learned if
you read the book and the letters are
each written in a different color
consistently as you read the book and if
you practice and practice you can get to
the point where you experience colors
when you're reading or hearing other
texts with alpha colors so in other
words your brain can be completely
transformed and the potential is
incredible you could that this is how
you would learn and be dexterity and I
think in general we're just not very
ambitious with the kind of things we're
trying to learn the extent to which the
brain can be changed means we could
learn whole new languages that are more
efficient than our own language and thus
make up thinking faster you know may be
more efficient that way I think what
would be interesting would be to take a
look at someone who has a particularly
remarkable brain and then to try a new
brain plasticity to actually make our
brains more like that so let's take n
Stein for example Einstein had a thicker
corpus callosum the corpus callosum is
the connection between the two parts of
the brain they
that increased his ability to
communicate across his entire brain and
to connect disparate ideas so you could
increase your own corpus callosum
thickness how by practicing with
ambidexterity for instance and be
dexterous people do have picot corpus
callosum so there you go use brain
plasticity to make the brain a little
more like Einstein Einstein also had
particularly large inferior parietal
lobes and they're ugly structured
specifically they had a reduced
Sylvian fissure what this essentially
means is that his nonverbal reason his
spatial reasoning was improved compared
with ours and if you look at the way he
describes coming up with ideas some of
his ideas such as very relatively
special theory of relativity he actually
describes that he was he would imagine
himself on a beam of light looking back
and experiencing what that would look
like or you describe dropping two things
off a roof and experience being one of
them falling so he had a very visual way
of thinking and this is potentially will
help them to come up with his rules of
physics which you know changed the world
so if you could increase your own
temporal parietal lobe inferior parietal
lobe then in theory you could gain some
of that kind of insight how do you do
that maybe through games you know
computer games they could increase your
visual thinking or perhaps maybe through
nonverbal reasoning exercises who knows
but the point is you could change your
brain again and this could lead to
greater insights like an AI that's
reprogramming itself to become smarter
we can do that with our own brains it's
actually possible now using certainly
traffics which have come on t for adults
to learn perfect pitch that's where you
hear a note and you know exactly what no
you're hearing and this is something
that they thought previously was either
something genetic but you've born with
or at least that it couldn't be learned
fast a certain age but great elasticity
is such that it can be learned so this
to me is the incredible and awesome
power of brain plasticity so now how do
we improve that brain plasticity what
can we do to enhance it well a lot of
people watching this channel are
interested in new tricks so let's start
their new tricks are brain enhancing
drugs for those who can't watch this
channel for their smart pills things
that you take that enhance your thinking
one way or another in theory anything
that would be excitatory for your
neurons would improve brain plasticity
so for instance modafinil
or been on for a certain reason being
that as I said the more focused you are
the more important you're breathing
something is and the more you produce
BDNF brain-derived neurotropic factor
this can be seen in Platteville memories
for instance if you think back to where
you were when Michael Jackson died you
might remember it because your brain was
like warm shocked I bet I remember
everything around me right now so if you
could focus on things and make them seem
more important to you you're more likely
to learn them and you can do that with
focus enhancing nootropics more
specifically you could do it with new
traffic's like lion's mane lion's mane
is a new trick that it's supposed to
increase nerve growth factor I haven't
tried it myself but if you look at the
anecdotal evidence and if you look at
the studies it does seem to work however
I wouldn't say it's a kind of order of
magnitude above what you normally would
experience so it's just there it's a
nice little upgrade as an age but don't
expect it to change your world as is the
case with many new tricks unfortunately
there's another supplement that I
reviewed on my site called sill Texas
base to improve long-term potentiation
the ability to strengthen existing
connections and also increase your
desire to learn according to some
reports still tech for me wasn't again
game-changing it was alright I sort of
liked it a lot of people described it as
a kind of natural time to do modafinil I
did not find it that way at all but hey
you know each to their own so these
kinds of nootropics ones that effect
your neurotransmitters I don't think are
particularly likely to complete change
everything for you unfortunately however
something that is very interesting that
seems to be able to enhance brain
plasticity is valproate in one study
this is the study where they talk to
people to learn perfect pitch using
evaporate unfortunately they've even
described it as unlocking the kind of
plasticity that we have in childhood
unfortunately battery also has a lot of
side effects and it's certainly not
recommended that you rush out and buy
any it's just
thing line of research and if you head
to my website you can get the study to
leave there so you know there's
potential for that but at the moment
we're not quite there yet perhaps at
this stage and more promising line of
inquiry is TVCs tcbs transcranial direct
current stimulation tDCS
this is where you attach electrodes to
your scalp to electrify your brain and
that might sound like you know suicide
but actually it's not used very low
currents going through that aren't even
active cause your brain to fire so
you're not stimulating your brain to
fires common misconception all you're
doing is potentiating them make them
slightly more excitable or like to fire
and this isn't even what increases the
this isn't even what brings about the
effects of the brain of the process
rather it's that this process increases
BDNF again brain derived neurotrophic
factor a lot of people have reported
that when they're using these
transcranial direct current stimulation
devices that they actually experience
enhanced learning and other positive
desirable effects what's really
interesting about this is that you can
also create specific effects by
enhancing the action of particular brain
areas and even by suppressing the action
of certain brain notes you have an anode
which is positive and a cathode which is
the negative you can suppress brain
activity with the cathode and increase
activity with the anode and you put
these in certain places on your brain
and this is called your montage and
using this they've managed to improve
specific abilities like the ability to
learn motor abilities so you could
increase your brain plasticity whilst
performing sports except check the West
Cupid headset and thereby potentially
learn perfect golf swing much more
quickly
you've got other ones which increase
your ability to to learn new languages
or ones that help you to focus on
computer games for instance people
actually using these headsets as one
called polka dot that's people actually
using these headsets in
Gaming competitions because they can
enhance their problem-solving and their
attention and their again I haven't used
this one myself except for once very
clean and I can't draw too many
conclusions from that
but again the studies are very promising
and the anecdotal evidence is great a
lot of people say that it has really
helped them they've even increased their
score on brain training tests things
like that again I don't think this is an
order of magnitude improvement but it's
a small improvement it's certainly one
worth paying attention to and if you're
looking for an interesting you know
promising field throwing cloak
increasing brain plasticity or you want
to run your own experiments I would say
that's the one to start with and I'll be
performing my name own experience what I
can actually wholeheartedly recommend
for increasing brain plasticity though
is just you know the boring stuff so
proper nutrition bitumen b12 omega-3
fatty acid I am all these things zinc
magnesium will improve your brain faster
s'ti getting proper sleep is one of the
best ways they say that's when a lot of
our memories our practice rehearsed in
the brain and memories are reinforced
the things you've learned and reinforced
exercise is fantastic of brain
plasticity and many studies have shown
that particularly aerobic exercise can
really boost your brain plasticity
through a number of different processes
so all these lifestyle factors getting
enough of your vital nutrients and sleep
and exercise that's really how you
improve your brain plasticity in a safe
way
likewise I would say getting plenty of
likewise just rehearsing learning
picking up new skills is fantastic for
brain plasticity and that's one of the
reasons they think that people who learn
a lot and actively seeking out new
information experience lesser decline as
they get older so you know learn new
languages the training computer games
they're they're fun every time you learn
them you can beat the game you're
learning new button combinations new
rules and your brain is rewiring
yourself you can feel this whatever you
played a computer game we have to change
the y-axis to go up and down and playing
for instance
you can actually feel your brain working
as you try and you know remap what's up
and what's down in your head that's very
good for you just doing that regularly
will increase the BDNF and it'll
increase your ability to learn new
things more per se learning new
languages is fantastic because it's such
a massive undertaking programming
languages all these things just keep
learning keep reading and your improved
ability to adapt and learn new things I
also am a big proponent of CBT cognitive
behavioral therapy that's using your own
thoughts to improve your cognition
normally CBT is used as a therapeutic
tool for treating phobias and things and
it means for instance telling yourself
why you don't need to be afraid of
spiders you know reminding yourself that
your fears aren't really grounded in
reality
etc and rehearsing positive things
testing etc CBT can be used to enhancing
your plasticity if you just convince
yourself that what you're doing what
you're learning is really important if
you remind yourself why you're doing it
and if you get yourself to the point
where you're having an even you know
it's this light fight for flight
response because you can convince
yourself that it's so important if you
do that then you'll increase the
dopamine and you'll increase the
norepinephrine and that will increase
the B D and F and then their growth
factor this is command over you in brain
and meditation can help with that to say
you know not very exciting but some
basic stuff like thinking correctly and
being healthy will improve your brain
plasticity and pointers as well that I'd
like to point out you don't actually
need to measure brain plasticity all
that much as I said our brains are
already incredibly plastic we can do all
these things like learning to balance
like learning echolocation when we lose
our eyesight like picking up synesthesia
all these things we can do with no need
to change our brains through drugs or
anything else taxi drivers have heavier
brains like I said cellists have larger
areas in their motor cortex
corresponding to the tips of their
fingers because that's what they use for
playing the instrument of course so
point being you don't actually need to
change anything your brain is plastic
enough and you wouldn't want it to be
super plastic either because if it was
then not only would you better learn
good thing
more quickly you'd be able to pick up
bad habits much more quickly you'd be
able to pick up phobias much more
quickly so our brains are the amount of
plastic that they are for a reason you
know
we've evolved these brains because these
rings turned out to be the best for our
survival and it was true then that it's
pretty much true now so while you might
be interested in using nootropic as a
kind of scalpel for occasions when you
need to sit down and do some real heavy
learning and I wouldn't even necessarily
say that that you know required actually
your brain is plastic enough from those
things and all you need to do is put in
the work then the effort and it's a lot
like body building you know there's no
shortcuts if you want to get the muscle
you need to go to the gym and if you
want to learn new skills you need to use
your brain training you need to train
your brain you need to practice you need
to learn new things and I think in the
future we'll have better tools for doing
this and there's a lot on brain training
at the moment several promising studies
being done into how you can use main
training to improve various abilities of
course the dual n-back training is
useful for improving your working memory
however I don't think improving your
working memory by like one point or you
know or improving your IQ at one point
is really worth all that much effort if
you take one thing away from this video
I don't be just the potential that you
bring to already do incredible things
that you can already learn any key
location without going blind I feel that
keen to that you can already learn
ambidexterity
that you could change the way you think
in order to be more efficient that you
could change your brain to be more like
Einstein I think this is where we should
be looking I think there's going to be a
lot more attention out in the future and
I think the ability to reprogram our own
minds is possibly you know what gives us
our most power our most potency in
freedom I think in the future as well
we might be using virtual reality tools
because imagine if you could emerge
immerse yourself in a world that was
completely different and practicing it
using virtual reality and then take your
head self imagine if you could
experience a world that was just a
couple of frames a second faster than
the real world
take head self would you be able to see
the world almost in slow motion
something worth thinking about anyways
I've rambled on long enough they found
this video interesting that's brain
plasticity in a nutshell and that's a
few of my ideas on the subject and
that's how you can potentially improve
it so yes hope you enjoyed it like I say
and I'll be uploading more videos on
similar topics as well as my usual
fitness technology life style etc if you
would like to watch more like that
then please subscribe like comment in
the comment section and I'll see you for
the next one bye for now thanks for
watching now thanks for watching